by the power of castle hate skull i am a
mark harley and today we're gonna start
off hot we're gonna start off smoking
piping hot
with a phone call that i had yesterday
with a stranger who hit me up and said
hey can i have some advice and i said
you know rather than endlessly going
back and forth with you like i
want to do with some people
but now realizing that it's very time
consuming to do that i say hey get on
the phone with me
let's schedule a time usually when i'm
driving to or from work i have some free
time
that i can say you know what this is
just free time i'd use uh listening to
something in the car so at the expense
of educating myself no it's fine it's
fine no i'll talk to you because
obviously bettering myself that can take
second fiddle to your needs as an
audience member who i've never met
before i'm just kidding
i enjoy doing stuff like this and again
it's no skin off my back
if i can do it in certain times of the
day that i can rationalize as
times of the day that i would have been
using for
entertainment right
and again
it's uh this person seems nice they seem
grateful they seem like a fan they seem
like they
are
doing some of the research themselves
they're not complete beginners where
it's like you know hey
google is your friend right so i end up
talking to this guy
i believe his name is scott
uh seemed like a really nice guy on the
phone he was very courteous that's
another thing when people are like
tell me your schedule and i will work
around that and very you know sort of
conscientious of like
i know i'm taking your time and i'm not
asking for anything return he actually
did pay me at the end of this which is
very nice but
i do not ask for that
you know if i'm not whatever saying that
up front i'm not going to pick and
that's 100 bucks but we got to talking
and the main thing that we talked about
because first i have to decipher what's
your experience level what can you
really do what you have access to
then it's about deciding you're split
right
and i helped him walk through deciding
his own split in a way that
i think
it occurs to me that not a lot of
beginners are aware that you can
essentially make up anything you want
now some would be better some would be
worse uh some are tried and true like
the push-pull leg system um you know
upper body lower body i think a lot of
beginners could probably benefit from
doing a very simple full body workout a
few times a week just hitting a few
basic movements to get those
repetitions in with you know the
overhead press the bench press the squat
the deadlift these very
simple exercises that you could benefit
from practice because you haven't
mastered if you're a beginner you have
not mastered the squat you have not
mastered the bench you've not mastered
the dead i'm still mastering these
things
and obviously i'm super advanced no it
is true
and i'll make tweaks i'm tweaking my
bench right now
starting over
feeling very weak
so this guy i could tell you had a
little bit of experience
and you kind of
you know you go how many times a week
can you work out
five days a week six days a week every
day whatever you want
you know if it's not a push-pull legs if
it's not a bro split where you're doing
one body part a day you can make a sort
of hybrid and what we arrived at was
essentially
doing
um a single body part every day so
something to the effect of
chest back and shoulders on separate
days but then two days out of the week
he would do arms
twice
right like sorry arms twice in a week
but that would be additional days
however you want to make that up like
you know
chest arms back arms shoulders and then
throughout the week another thing we
decided this is another unconventional
layer to what we're doing is that he
would do legs a little bit of legs every
single day and that's something that i'm
a big advocate of because
people
who think that the only way to work your
legs
is an all-out hardcore leg day in which
you do multiple exercises you know a
barbell compound lift a leg press a
lunge a donkey kick a hamstring curl a
romanian deadlift all these different
things
i just think that's a sort of outdated
model it's a great bodybuilding model
if you're accustomed to high volume if
you're a masochist
if
you think that's the best thing for you
if you really enjoy doing a full leg day
where you hit every single part of your
legs that's great but for a lot of
people
it's very intimidating it's very
exhausting if you have a normal job or
have to function during the day
and you want to do a leg day for example
during the week in the morning
well
that's going to exhaust you for the rest
of the day and maybe put a damper on the
other things that you have to do right
you're going to feel exhausted maybe
even a little bit nauseous i've had many
leg days where i end up feeling nauseous
i imagine that casey
working out in crossfit gyms
have you ever been nauseous i have yeah
there's i mean there's one uh workout in
particular that's kind of a benchmark
workout called fran uh-huh uh and that's
like 21-15-9
of thrusters with 95 pounds and pull-ups
what was the number at the beginning
again so you do 21 15 and then nine like
but no break you're supposed to do it as
fast as you can and like it's a it's it
oh
exercises thrusters just yeah thrusters
at 95 pounds and pull-ups and so it's
designed to be completely unbroken you
do it as fast as you can and
like the time domain should be under
five minutes like my fastest frame time
was like 240. my brother did it in like
208 someone one time went sub two
minutes it's like but that one like i
say after that if i go all out on that
workout like it feels like my teeth are
itchy like you just and it takes like
you've got the glitchy teeth boy it'll
take you like 30 minutes to recover from
like a sub three-minute all-out effort
yeah and that's that's another amazing
little side note is
what you can do you want to go all out
for three to five minutes you know or
even if it takes you six or whatever
somewhere in that range is potentially
going to make your nauseous off of two
exercises but what i hear when i hear
thrusters plus pull ups is full body
yeah right because you're getting um you
know a leg movement you're getting a
push movement you're getting a pull
movement
so it's covering essentially your whole
body in a compound in you know with
compound movements
and that tends to be highly exhausting
but um
you know i think everybody should
experience that but you're not trying to
do that every time you work out right no
i don't do that anymore i would get like
anxiety before doing that type of thing
right because it's like this is about to
hurt i'm trying to beat the [ __ ]
student odds to my left and to my right
like
it was a
you know a competitive kind of thing you
know just for fun but like you know once
you're like hey i'm gonna try and beat
you then it's like all right now i'm now
i'm nervous once your entire identity is
based around crossfit
no but i feel that like because some
lifting days are fun and some aren't
yeah right some like and leg day can
cause anxiety with a lot of people so i
reframe it
and only if you know it's like okay it's
one thing if like this sucks but you're
doing it a lot of people go leg day
sucks i don't want to do it or i'm doing
it you know
a tenth as much as the other days
because whatever i always was always
training for football so
it felt like it was imperative for me to
do leg days that felt like there was a
consequence to not doing them that
wasn't just physique oriented so this
guy was talking about how he gets
nervous or doesn't like doing like this
so i said let's try two sets a day of
something right so if you're lifting
five days a week as outland
that would be you know one day you're
doing squat one day you're doing
remaining deadlift one day you're doing
lunge one day you're doing uh
hamstring curls and another day you're
doing leg
extensions and if that isn't
five days then i don't know what to tell
you and maybe swap out like lunges for
leg press or something like that but i
go
you can do
i said one to three but let's say you do
two that's still valuable right or even
doing two hard sets five days a week
that's 10 hard sets
done throughout the week for your legs
total not bad right that's gonna at
least keep you progressing into
something that even if you're doing
bench press or something you get to the
end of the workout you're like oh i
forgot to do my leg extensions or you
can throw this in there so that was a
wrinkle that i threw in there where
you're kind of modifying like this you
know full body five days a week that's
the approach you take of spreading this
volume out through the entire week you
take
the the leg portion of that idea spread
your leg volume out to two sets every
day
you do a
semi bro split and then you do arms
twice a week the reason for that is
because
he said uh you know that was a lagging
body part so there's an idea that i
think not a lot of people know about who
are beginning that it's like yeah you
can lift you know four five
six times a week on the same muscle
potentially depending on the volume and
intensity right if you're in prison
doing push-ups every day
um for for those prison inmates out
there know what i'm talking about if
you're doing push-ups every single day
it's not like you're going to degrade
your muscle right it's just volume
intensity if you're so sore you can't do
a single push-up we'll probably don't do
it then um
you know and it's all that's available
to you but you know heavy deadlifting
every day probably not so there's also
an element of
stimulus and fatigue if it's too
fatiguing and too damaging and there's
too much stress on your joints for that
thing then don't do it every day but
just just start targeting the muscle
group with you know slightly different
movements every day that's fine and
something a complex system of individual
muscles like the legs or the back
you can get away with doing higher
frequency if the angles are changed
every time or the movement you know it's
like you know
your leg extensions and hamstring girls
have nothing in common so it's totally
fine to them
back to back and if you have a lagging
body part
right rather than trying to do
everything every single day
and you can i've done up to you know
three four
five times a week of the same muscle but
specifically if you have a lagging body
part try to do it more right you can be
doing everything else once a week and
you say i want to bring up my chest do
it three times a week right and have
that be the only thing until it catches
up or you're happy with it and move on
to something else right shoulders or
whatever one or two body parts you can
increase the frequency on but
that requires some creativity and people
are always uncomfortable with that going
well it's not a pushable legs it's not
this bro smooth that i got from arnold
schwarzenegger which by the way i've
recently read what his split was back in
the day it's kind of terrible i really
you know the arnold gets away with
genetics and just you know
an insane amount of volume and intensity
right so it's almost like you're gonna
do great no matter what you do
but
it's not the most efficient way doing
chest and back on the same day with
super sets and all the volume he did it
just doesn't turn out to be and even the
rep schemes
i was reading through where i saw a
video where somebody was uh you know
sort of detailing the rep schemes
they're honestly atrocious and we just
we've moved beyond that so don't go
picking up like an arnold book and
thinking that's the be-all end-all you
can figure it out for yourself if you
kind of just
get in touch with what your principles
are what do you want to do right and
take some of this some of that some of
that
and make your own thing and similarly
with diet right i'll always reiterate
this but
you're going to have to
think about that creatively as well at
some point you know it's good to try
different things like keto like
carnivore like whatever a moderate
carbohydrate high protein diet
you can look something up online you can
figure out your macros you can get these
estimates but ultimately you're putting
things in place and for this guy
you know he was telling me specifically
that he wanted to and most guys right
this is a conversation i've had where
because i've become a
a lightning rod if you will
in catalin almost every episode of t-fat
gay will go you know if i wanted to gain
muscle
if i wanted to get jacked but i don't
think guys look at me and go i want to
be as big as you
and even if they did they certainly want
to wouldn't want to like consume the
calories or put in the time or whatever
most guys
really comes down to i want to put on a
few pounds of muscle and strip a few
pounds of fat and that's very doable
but
you're going to sort of have to take
this
body recomposition approach which for
those of you who have not listened to me
before
the basic template is 50 of your protein
50 of your calories from protein then
split the rest between carbs and fats so
you can start out at 25 25
and adjust from there
you know some people do well with more
carbs some people do it well with more
fat and a basic principle also is to try
to limit
you know carbs and fats together or
doing really you know like having a meal
that's just carbs and fat because when
the insulin spikes from the
carbohydrates
um you know more fat is going to be
transported and stored in
you know or sorry more more you know fat
is going to be
stored as energy rather so
apply those basic principles if you're
somebody who wants to lose weight but
still gain muscle at the same time the
deficit's got to be there it's got to be
slight right so only a few hundred
calories
and
then you go let me figure out what i
like to eat
as i'm always doing with these hella
chef harley things it's about figuring
out what works for you what can i buy
from costco what can i repeat day in and
day out for at least a month for at
least a few weeks for at least you know
a few months maybe then when you get
sick of it you swap it out
speaking of fantastic colored shirts
that i'm wearing and no in case you
laugh but you're the person who brought
it up to me said wow that shirt looks
really good on you specifically with the
purple background behind you
specifically it looks like the la lakers
are going
to have a game later today a lot of
people have been asking me mark do you
play for the la lakers i said no it's
just the effect that oakenstone clothing
has
on virtually anybody that wears their
clothes is it makes you look like a
professional athlete what can i say
i was actually talking to ricardo
yesterday and
um
you know i do a lot of these these funny
promos and talk about how great the
clothes are um and he likes that and i
like that too but also
you know we hear a lot from people who
are like
i bought the clothes and a lot of people
bought them we had a nice promo
in uh for july
uh with an extra you know percentage off
and that was fantastic so i saw a lot of
people bought for the first time and i
get messages that are that are real that
go you know people are surprised by the
quality so i know they look nice and
everything but i think once you feel the
quality and the durability you can just
tell it's a shirt that's gonna last for
a long time right so it's not some h m
you know ten dollar shirt that's
gonna fall apart after three washings uh
they're durable but both you know it's
like there's a durability but a
breathability to it right everybody's
impressed the customer service
experience people are always like oh
yeah i had a problem i didn't know how
to apply the promo code and you know i
sent an email and then ricardo called me
back on the phone uh it's a really cool
thing and people like that because you
know customer service is something that
you don't always get from every company
but you do get it with oak and stone and
also everybody who's ordered
you know i haven't had one displeased
uh customer yet come to me and say used
your promo code bought something and i
didn't actually like it people like the
clothes and in fact they're sort of
beyond you know they're impressed beyond
what their expectations were so
um
what i'm saying is check it out and i'm
even thinking you know maybe i'll just
announce it here
i'm thinking about a promo for august
and i'm thinking
you know with these uh consultations
that i've been giving out
perhaps
if you buy an oak stone shirt and send
me the receipt for your order just a
screenshot of what you ordered right
send it to me does it have to be you
know 10 different items buy one thing
buy one shirt
send it to me
and i'm going to say it right here right
now
i will give you a 20 minute phone
consultation to talk about whatever you
want oh my god right lifting
diet
uh workout splits
uh and we don't have to talk about where
you don't have to you know talk about
you can just say mark i just want to
know where do you come up with these
amazing ideas for skits at the gym i'll
talk to you about that all day
and i uh you know will stutter through
the entire conversation so that 20
minutes will only be one sentence but
i've been thinking about it i want to do
that and want to give people who who
give me some value some value back so
it's the least i can do to people who
really do support me
and uh you know use promo code hello if
you don't use a promo code i don't can i
really give you the discount i don't
know i'd like to you know
i'd love to i just can't okay so use the
promo code because oops sorry that's
kind of where i draw the line got it
openstoneclothing.com use code hello for
10 off and guess what
20 minute phone consult
that will be fulfilled
by the latest end of september okay
pinky swear
all right let's get into some happy
hippo herbals
some hella happyhippo herbals.com
that's my new segment okay we're gonna
talk about kratom happy hippo
herbals.com is the place where i get my
kratom
it's a place where i get
creative in liquid form in powder form
and pill form because yes i still use it
as my favorite all-natural nootropic
substance and
in an industry where you can't always
trust what you're ordering from because
it's the wild wild west you have random
manufacturers saying yeah this is kratom
yeah it's pure yeah it's good is it
though happy hippocrates though i know
and i trust and i use the quality
that they deliver and i'm totally happy
with it so once you find a place like
that i just don't see a whole lot of
utility in
taking a risk elsewhere right i found
this place
i love the quality i love the delivery
mechanisms they give me and so i'm
sticking with it and i hope you do too
and i hope you get that 20 off for life
on every order using promo code
what i'm currently doing
in our next hello chef harley
is a shake that i've invented all by
myself with simple ingredients that are
already in my house right we know i was
eating protein pancakes for a while
there
when the time has come
rough gotten sick of them
i don't
i confess i haven't been even so
this happens right this happens where
you go
you're really hot and like when you like
something to eat eat it every day i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that because you can look forward to
healthy foods the protein pancakes were
a healthy food that i was looking
forward to
and also the more you prepare something
you kind of get faster and better at
doing it it becomes mindless you should
do these things until it becomes
mindless
but i found myself even if that takes 20
minutes to prepare pancakes
it's like oh 20 20 minutes still 20
minutes right it's not five minutes when
you're rushing out the door so
to mix batter and get like
you know the batter the protein the bowl
oh the bowl is dirty got to clean it out
get the whisk get the pan get the spray
the pan do you know and do a pancake one
at a time and then sit down and eat it
that process again if i could just you
know mainline that into my veins i would
but then it also takes away the fun of
eating pancakes in the morning so
i decided to swap it out with something
a little bit quicker now some of those
basic ingredients are still there what i
have is the cake pop protein it's a
great base
this is why i really recommend this
flavor it's better than vanilla whatever
they got going on there pe science i
don't work for them i don't promote them
but the cake pop is a great base for
this
following recipe
you're gonna do
two scoops kpop a bunch of ice a
tablespoon of peanut butter don't go
nuts with it but this is going to fill
you up we've got a little more fat
because we're doing a little bit less
carbs
put in a banana okay
and a drizzle of honey and then a couple
tablespoons each of hemp seeds and chia
seeds so what you have is a high protein
higher fat but it's a healthy fat
polyunsaturated fats
a bunch of ice and it just tastes really
good the banana the peanut butter
try it out you're gonna love it it's
fantastic
and that's something you can make
you know
at five minutes is very generous right
it's very generous it's gonna take you
most likely much less time
and that will fill you up for hours
again i'm always thinking about like if
i get out the door if i can just get
this in my system right now
i'm going to make better choices later
that's another thing that diet is about
to me is just going
if i can get this in my body now i'm
less likely to stop the mcdonald's on
the way in
right oh my god
[Laughter]
no bubblegums this week
but uh
you know
throughout the day i just find if you
can get in sometimes i'll just like
yesterday
i didn't have a chance to eat breakfast
and i just brought brown rice in a brown
rice cup and just eating that though
it's like at least you have something
and you're going to crave shittier
carbohydrates much less so do it right
even though i'm sort of violating my own
principle of going have protein in every
meal
sometimes that's not always possible you
didn't grab it on the way out but you do
that you do the halfway you get
something is better than nothing and
you're setting yourself up for a success
what else you have to say about this guy
he
the conversation yeah was just like
i'm gonna encourage you to be creative
i'm gonna encourage you to to figure it
out and not feel like
oh i didn't i tried keto i didn't like
it therefore i failed right i tried this
one food this recipe i didn't like it i
failed
give yourself six months of
experimentation to find out what you can
actually stick to and you're setting
yourself up for long-term success get
the deficit slight see if you can lose a
little bit of weight consistently over
time as you get stronger and that sets
you up for long-term success
because you do a crash diet
you know you restrict yourself to a
thousand calories it's just it's never
going to be the best option right unless
you literally have to you know try to
make weight or something like that
any ufc fighters
in the audience
thought not
what else do we have today okay you know
i
i went straight to the hello chef i went
to the bro science academy let's take a
back step to my first deep tissue
massage
luana and i went for a couple's massage
for our anniversary on august 7th
uh we were massaged simultaneously by
two asian men
now i gotta be honest here i had
a sort of uh traumatizing experience the
last time we did a couple's massage
also uh being massaged by a small asian
man and i didn't know who this was you
know this time i looked i made sure to
see who was massaging me because during
the massage last time for valentine's
day let's say 2020
i noticed that during the massage
when my hand was being moved you know
like from this position to that position
it seemingly you know brushed this guy's
penis like in a way where i'm like did
you mean to put my hand across here
that's standard they all do that that's
normal if you're not touching a penis
it's not a massage right right
no i i you know that is some people's
philosophy if you
if uh if the masseuse isn't using your
hand to touch his penis
is it really a massage right i don't
know yeah that's that's what i was
trying to do it's an age-old question i
think that
uh you know confounds many of our
nation's top philosophers to this day
happens once happens twice and i'm you
know like it's funny to me that's the
thing i could say
like
i almost wanted to be more grossed out
but i'm like the first it's like is this
really happening you know am i being
molested in a massage parlor right now
kind of a reverse happy ending
yeah
it was a sad ending
i went to a massage barley i got the
saddest ending i've ever had
uh because at the ending i'm like
was i just taken advantage of by
an asian twink
because
i mean
like it's happened it's happened once
then perhaps twice then like then like
maybe he's brushing me like like there's
all these little moments during the
massage you forget where it's like turn
over and then you're like pressing out
the sheets or something it's like did he
just rub my dick again you know um
but honestly it was just funny because
this kid couldn't weigh more than 120
pounds and it's like good for him you
know yeah i'm sure he's sexually
frustrated and can you blame him i mean
this hunk of man-meat walks in the
massage parlor how are you not touching
his dick um
but
so
wanna actually going into this she's
like are you okay to do this i'm like
huh she's like are you sure you're not
traumatized from last time
traumatized this is a fantastic story
but
i was going to be traumatized in a
different way because
i've never had a deep tissue massage
before but
they gave me the choice this time i said
you know like you're filling out the
little form or whatever and
it goes you know thai swedish deep
tissue
and i said oh deep tissue like that
sounds like something i could use right
about now so i opted for that as luana
was getting a swedish massage next to me
swedish massage is like relaxing and you
know it's just more it's lighter i guess
right you're using the hot rocks and
stuff like that
i was over here doing my best not to
scream out loud probably 30 different
times
because it was one of i have a pretty
high pain threshold and
this was just like objectively very
painful um
turned out to be great but
like
specific parts of your body like
if somebody's putting as much pressure
as they can against your trapezius
rubbing it against the ribs
your calf have you ever had your calf
like really rolled and stepped on it was
like
you know but
i'm i was doing like this you know in
the the into the into the circular
face pad just going
[Music]
uh i use i don't know i don't know like
i was trying not to be hurt because you
kind of go
i want to be a man and not
demonstrate how i'm feeling in this
instance but if it goes any harder i'm
going to have to scream and turn around
and go please stop please that was
enough i you know i thought i could do
the deep tissue turns out
i'm a swedish guy so let's just let's do
a switcheroo mid massage all right
but turned out great um
because
something happened where i have my own
little theory of like okay he's pressing
super hard against my trapezius i have
this numb area
in the back of my
uh shoulder blade
it's all related i have a broken rib
back here i have a [ __ ] up shoulder
all this stuff where you know there's
pain when i do this why you know this
also like this is part of my
you know
your scapula moving
somehow
beating the [ __ ] out of my lower
trapezius loosen that up it feels better
it opened up movement in this vector
right like i can do
i can go farther back
with this arm now i have more feeling in
my back you know it was literally like
numb in certain places
i know you guys don't give a [ __ ] i'm
just saying try out first of all try it
out because you're going to see how
painful it is if you haven't done it
before then secondly you know maybe
something gets opened up for you who
knows
maybe it's your heart
okay
today in hella psychedelics
i wanted to talk about brian callan's
trip
he came in
to the fighter and the kid
on monday talking about how he took six
grams of mushrooms
now a hero's dose is five if you've ever
taken mushrooms you would know that an
eighth
is 3.5 grams or maybe you have taken
mushrooms and you're not some sort of
weight mathematician so you don't know
that 3.5 grams is an eighth but i do and
i know the first time i ever took
mushrooms i did half an eighth and that
was pretty strong that was enough for me
to be super giggly to feel like when i
was separated from my group for a little
bit i'm like oh no i'm freaking out i
want to be with the guys that are doing
mushrooms not the drinking football
players that are coming up to me
i remember my boys came up to me and
they're like what are you doing and i
admitted that i was on shrooms and
they're like oh my goodness is crazy
don't ever do that to somebody on
psychedelics it's the wrong move not the
right move
and
um
since then i have done shrooms many
times i've had good experiences i've had
bad experiences i've never done six
grams that's a lot i don't know how many
times brian has done mushrooms before i
know he's done tmd it almost sounded
like he
hadn't done them before like but i know
he's done dmt
but
he was describing this experience as if
it was the first time for him taking
this particular substance casey do you
know anything about whether or not he's
taking it for the first time uh i can't
i can't be i don't have that level of
intimate knowledge without him
ryan all the time about his psychedelics
i'm not so let's assume for the sake of
this ear pursuit that
that he did in fact take shrooms for the
first time
six grams is
a pretty intense dose even three grams
he described going to heaven right he
described i'm a genie in a bottle you
gotta rub he said i'm a genius bottle
right
and
everything was good and pure and
relaxing and you're sort of
um you know
no stress right one of the things that i
brought up is the
psilocybin and lsd
they bear a similar
resemblance to the serotonin molecule so
uh you know it agonizes the serotonin
receptors is
one idea there and
i've always noticed that yes on the way
up at least
the one of the first things you notice
in addition to color saturation is a
sense of well-being it's like oh i'm in
a good mood
i described it as effervescence or um
like carbonation
it felt like if my brain's a lid you pop
the top and it's like something's sort
of fizzing to the top which is a
pleasant feeling right
and uh maybe it's like alcohol where on
the ascending curve of that saturation
you're euphoric you feel good
everything's great but then you know it
reaches a certain point where you're
coming down because for a lot of people
can switch suddenly so he took three
had a really
positive intense time and then he took
three he's like you know what this is so
good i'm gonna double down
six beers is great 12 must be awesome
uh and i would describe that as probably
like a similar thing you know it's like
you haven't drunk before and it's like
you're taking two or three drinks
you know and then you're like i know
that through let's do that again right
or from you know whatever it is six is
drunk and it's like i'm an amazing
perfect drunk and then you take 12.
doubling something isn't always the best
way to go about it and he described
going to hell right that it was like he
felt like he was stuck in an eternity in
a
um
you know
he felt like
you're in a purgatory of some sort like
you can't get out of it like
everything's going wrong and you're
trapped and you're in pain
and that is a real
phenomenon for psychedelics you can
suddenly feel like
you know
it's too much i can't
escape in the same way that
positive feelings thoughts emotions are
all streaming on the way up uh negative
thoughts and paranoid thinking can
strike you on the way down and it's not
pleasant but i do think you can reverse
course
you know especially when you have
somebody
around you that's why you do it with
other people so they can talk you out of
it they can put on a pleasant song they
can remind you of where you are they can
ground you in time and space because
that's sort of the antidote you know to
going off to these crazy places as being
like you're here right now it's a
thursday night you're um you know in
your best friend's apartment or in this
case he was doing like a ceremony with
his friends and just being reminded that
can bring you
back to earth i don't mean to scare
anybody off who hasn't done it
but
i feel like you should just use more
responsibly you know if you take a dose
and it's going good resist the
temptation
to take twice as much right or even
before you take three grams take one
gram right that should do something to
you and it should give you an indicator
of
is this something that i ever want to do
again right is this something that i
want to take two grams of um
and also just as far as frequency it's
like you don't need to be
you know
this isn't something that's going to be
physically or psychologically addictive
and that's what i think is cool about
psychedelics is
um
you're never going to be like an addict
feeding from mushrooms right now some
people do do them every day i've seen
this before
they're called homeless losers but
you know the
the effect of psychedelics wears off so
quickly as far as building up a
tolerance that it's not just a good
long-term strategy you know so take it
once a quarter take it every season
thank me later you're welcome
oh my god
hater of the week i just wanted to do a
quick summary we haven't done hate of
the week for a while but this guy
messaged me recently and he was like
um i get this frequent accusation that
i'm using words that i don't understand
right
and
no casey knows this is true because we
have discussions after each podcast he
goes look i counted six words but i know
for a fact we're on your google search
history
three minutes before the podcast yeah
and i'll quiz you yeah who quiz me i'm
happy to quiz you right it's like i you
know i if you did know him that'd be one
thing yeah
but you were oh for six buddy
so i'll get accused of um
trying to sound smart which is always an
interesting thing because i feel like it
immediately reveals like if you're
telling me that i'm trying to sound
smart it's like
does listening to me
make you feel dumb or something because
i just i can't personally think of
using a word that i don't know how to
use and i try to just go
this is accurate
right this is the most accurate word and
sometimes i'll use a word like
juxtaposition because it sounds nice
right you do have these favorite words
as far as aesthetics go but
um
if i used a word and realized i didn't
know
what it was i think i would call myself
out because it'd be sort of embarrassing
i mean like it's much less embarrassing
to call yourself out being like i think
that's what that word means but i don't
know then to be like to actually have
somebody call you out and go use this
word in the wrong way and you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about right
that would personally bother me a lot
more now to date a lot of people have
accused me of that or being a
pseudo-intellectual that's one
that i accused of a lot in the comments
at least or people message me in this
case
i challenge the guy
i say okay like if that's your
um you know in your rant of a paragraph
if your accusation is i don't know how
to use words or i'm using words to seem
intelligent that i don't actually know
the meaning of name one
and he said
you don't know the definition of
pseudo-intellectual i'm like oh you
you're confused here because that's what
other people have been accusing me of
and i'm just repeating that that's not
something that i'm coming up with off
the top of my head you know but i do
know what sue intellectual means and my
definition of that would be something
along the lines of
somebody who is attempting to appear
as an intellectual
by using
esoteric language that's
i did it again you don't know what else
um
eckhart tolle comes to mind or there's
something like deepak chopra where these
guys are like you know
the pure metaphysical vitality of the
backwards notion of reverse cemetery
antagonism like like when you actually
evaluate their sentences there's a lot
of use of like metaphysically speaking
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
know it's like
it's what a smart person seems like to a
dumb person that's kind of what i think
of a pseudo intellectual somebody who's
attempting to
confuse the reader almost like just
enough like you understand the words or
most of them but then there's a vocab
word in there it's like
it's like
in the attempt
to sound like a genius you're being fake
deep and fake intellectual
and
using sentence speaking in grammatically
potentially grammatically correct
sentences but
ultimately
meaningless sentences right so you know
that you could map them out and go yes
this has a subject and a predicate and
you know
a transitive verb but
if you were to ask that person to
describe their meaning in a simpler way
they couldn't do it because there is no
meaning so you can't repackage something
in a more simple way to deliver the same
meaning if it didn't have meaning in the
first place get it
just off the top of my head but it's
something that
i think is worth scrutinizing if i was a
legitimate pseudo-intellectual
come at me bro
come at me with your best
attack on the fake intellectualism that
i'm promoting because i don't even think
i promote intellectualism i'm not an
intellectual
but i do try to consume
the work of intellectuals
and also
the milk of female intellectuals i drink
it on a daily basis you see
this guy ends up
we go back and forth and i love in the
process of this it was like
you're like he was using your
incorrectly like you know like you're a
fake intellectual like multiple times um
but with spelling it like the possess of
your so i'm like oh it's you know you
can't call somebody to intellectual when
you don't know how to use grammar
and this all ended with him claiming to
be
a multi-millionaire which i think was an
interesting response if you're like
if you go on somebody's page and go
you're a fake intellectual and you go
prove it and you're like i have 44
million dollars
from investing in oil and gas and you're
still paying at the pump little does he
know that i drive a prius
game over [ __ ]
but
he also had professional grappler as his
bio and i did take the time to look up
some of his grappling matches he's a
blue belt who's owned two at least from
what i found on youtube so there's that
right the claim that your professional
grappler has about as much
veracity as the claim that you have 44
million dollars
but are still
taking the time out of your day to call
me a pseudo intellectual on instagram
hey you know use some of that 44 million
dollars
and hire somebody
to teach you
the difference between your
and you are
got it
cool
awesome great
this is why we can't have nice gyms okay
this is why we just can't have them oh
my god
it's the dreaded
ghost elliptical
ghost hunters where are you when we need
you
nobody can explain this all right go
ahead and try how is this elliptical
moving by itself oh there's wind mark no
there isn't look at the trees in the
background okay
yes i'm an investigative journalist
yes i'm a detective yes i'm an outdoor
gym detective
hey ghosts need to work on their cardio
that's the thing yeah it's like dude
we're entering a whole new era where
it's like sure you may have been a fat
ghost but you can always change that oh
everybody's saying john cena oh
we solved it john cena is on the
elliptical boys
all right what's this next one this is
why we can't have nice golf courses oh
you know i bet me i couldn't hit it over
the fence
we have so many volume on that i think
he says something there
okay casey how would you rate his swing
though
let's see well the problem is it's so
muddy so he can't plant his feet yeah
excuses excuses it's actually good that
he slipped here because that's showing
that he's
engaging the ground forces which you
need to do to generate velocity and
speed there we go if if this was like a
sand shot where you don't want to use
your your the ground or your feet it's
kind of more just upper body and arms
that's okay but the fact that he's
engaging with the ground here is a good
sign now let's keep going right okay
he's coming in super steep his feet are
going in the right direction um but
that's too slippy you gotta under and
the ball is teed up so this is the t so
there's a couple things here
this t is in terrible condition the t
should be the most aside from the green
the most pristine part of the course i
mean
tee off so this tea is garbage is course
i'm guessing is garbage um but don't tee
off there if it's muddy
you got what you deserve no is he saying
for or just
was that one of those like you knocked
the wind out of yourself and all you can
do is go
how embarrassing is that because that's
happened to me so many times you're not
going wind out of yourself and i
remember this dude punched me in the
stomach when i was in like elementary
school and i was trying to talk [ __ ]
back to him he just punched my stomach
out of nowhere he's like a sixth grader
and i'm a third grader and he hits me in
the stomach for no reason
and i'm trying to talk [ __ ] back and i'm
like
he can't breathe you know
was he black yes okay
hence the ha this [ __ ] yo check
it out
um
this is
this is why we can't have nice beaches
this guy is 300 pounds and etched a
six-pack into his stomach hair we got to
give it up because obviously this guy's
doing it as a joke but like to do that
and just show up to the beach and just
rock that and then also he's going to
get that tan too he's going to have
those liver king block abs
red puffy swollen
but honestly when you shave the rest of
that off it's like you might fool some
people with terrible vision
what do we got next here how about a oh
she's getting ready for the party
tonight look at that now what i like
about this is it's kind of total bs
first of all this woman looks in shape
who's bouncing her ass like she already
looks like she has a nice ass
but this also looks like first of all if
you do that enough it probably does work
she's got a barbell on her back
she's bouncing up and down
like she's riding some d on that swiss
ball
if you do that enough you probably would
get a burn right but it just looks
utterly ridiculous and also what are you
doing right well why don't you just do
the normal thing why don't you just do
it without it there right why don't you
use no momentum it's another one of
these things that it looks like
something you'd see at only fitness
or planet fitness or something like that
where it's like it's uh it's almost but
who taught you that right who put that
idea into your hands that that's the
best way to build your butt cheeks
because i think you just made it up
because you're mentally ill
what do we have next
this is why we can't have nice soccer
games oh he hits the kid once he hits
another kid and then
oh he
he went for the hat trick
of destroying small children's faces i
mean what are the odds you know you
think about this and you go like what
are the odds that somebody's filming
this terrible game of soccer because if
i'm a parent i'm going i'm not filming
any of this this is not a game right
casey this is the hardest you've ever
laughed at a video but i had the same
thing earlier like when i found this i
really cracked up
longer you know and i don't feel bad
cause like okay they're all fine it's
just like the three in a row this has
old school america's funny so it does
right because it's like innocent
nobody's really getting that hurt but
it's like just the
what are the odds you know like you know
do you know about the like statistics of
uh you know you flip a coin people go
what's what's going to be um
the chances of you flipping a coin on
the third you know you do one two three
if you if you
flip a coin and it hits heads once
then hits heads twice
the third time it still has 50 50 odds
for heads and tails but if you looked at
it cumulatively like the um what is it
called embedding oh the parlay right
what's the parlay on that third you know
then it's like 0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5
um
this is like that right the odds are
multiplying uh to reduce the chance
uh to a smaller and smaller percentage
you're taking the fun out of it i know i
really don't it's okay these are
astronomical odds what i'm saying
there's a reason that we haven't seen
this before ever in life three kids
getting kicked hard in the face because
they all like whiplash back it's not
like it's like just bounced off your
head at low speeds like
that kid can kick is the thing like he
has good i wonder if he's really good
maybe he is doing it on purpose you know
who gets it the hardest
the last kick is he was falling forward
uh
you know they'll they'll bust their face
and then they run into each other but
that kid is like rushing forward and
almost stumbling and then it's like boom
and he whiplashes his head all the way
back
and that's one of the best clips i think
we've ever seen and this is why we can't
have nice skate parks i want your read
on this casey
because i was kind of astounded i'm like
who is the person doing this the kid
goes up for a backflip on like this
cement half pipe thing and somebody
blasts him with like a a glitter gun
mid-air what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
rollerbladers travel with glitter guns
i had to get out in front of that one
you're not doing
i had to get out in front it was good
that was really good uh but like who
brings that to a skate park and then
who's like i know when he's upside down
and his neck is exposed to the cement
i'm gonna blast him in the face
i think he over rotated it more so than
the glitter gun okay you're not wrong
but i wonder if you could correct it you
know and i guess even just looking at
going
like yeah he probed right but now would
he have turned back around at that last
second did it disrupt
no i think he looks skilled enough that
uh he's probably used to glitter guns
he's been rolling long i've got to get
out in front of this like mark actually
i know the guy was part of the whole
prank
it was totally his fault he got up and
said look i wanted him to shoot the
glitter in my face
when i'm doing a backflip and uh you
know being a quadriplegic is honestly
not as bad as i thought it would be
um but again
different people like that where it's
like hey dude don't prank me while i'm
like jumping off of you know the stairs
or something
when i'm about to you know do a cliff
dive into like
you know craggy rocks here and you're
like you know push me or something
not not cool not fun not cool
so the the
caption for this one is bro is playing
chess we're playing checkers i couldn't
agree more he goes up to this girl
she's on uh the rower here
and he goes can i work in
now if you agree to that what does that
mean
not like you're going to take turns on
reps because this is a steady state
cardio exercise so he hops on behind her
and all of a sudden we're witnessing a
romantic moment now they're dating so
there's a happy ending right
could have gone either way could have
gone like whoa we're calling the cops
this is a me too thing but turns out
it went to the romance side right it was
a romantic comedy
not a tragedy
here's just a good old-fashioned gym
fail right she's trying to do cable
crunches
and the cord just snapped and sometimes
you just have shitty pieces of equipment
at the gym but also this is why you
don't do cable crunches huh maybe pick a
better exercise
because i hate those i don't think
they're good i think you can do it on an
app machine don't do that that's a
lesson to you
and uh you were taught that by a hundred
and twenty pound girl who smacked your
face on the ground
this is
this is why we can't have nice slides
look at this dude
so this is already a gigantic slide it
from the water park
this is a 300 pound 65 year old man
jumping from
i would assume like 10 feet on top of
the slide
and he gets so much air you can see him
squirming in the air
right it's just like not like that's
dangerous per se except if he smacks his
belly on the ground but it's like just
you know that sensation like you're so
up and like you're like whoa this was
way more than i expected and he's
flailing in the air
to try to find his balance
i kind of want to go to that water park
now am i going to jump off that thing no
because i feel like what if you broke
your leg jumping into it what if you
like caught your ankle and it's like
you're like sliding down for those three
seconds
with your uh limbs you know your leg
flailing all about and then you get
launched up in the air you're like my
leg is broken
sorry just be sad right
but kind of cool like what if you could
just see like you know it's like a
mcgregor like flop entry and just like
[Music]
different video different podcasts you
know
except the tone we're going for
and i titled this one this is why
we can't have a nicer gym across the
street because our friend it's dream
swirl i think is his ig name
amazing lifter terrible ig handle
he is carrying
what looks to be
six plates across the street just
walking walking walking
585 pounds is so heavy
i can't express that to you enough even
when i put on three plates i'm always
like 225 feels
like not that much and then once i go up
to 300 like yep that's still 300 pounds
compressing my spine so
585 pounds i've never had on my back but
i wouldn't recommend this because even
at that weight
even just locking at your knees can be
tough but goddamn that guy is a freak of
nature
[Music]
and uh
this guy's doing a bunch of way in a
dead lift and just collapses like we let
we love dead lips collapse videos and
the guy behind him just couldn't be less
phased and gets up and smacks his hand
like he just knew everything was gonna
be all right
could you say this was staged i feel
like
right it's a little too natural and you
do snap out of it so
what do we think about that case i think
i think it's real yeah it does have the
the uh
because also like the security cam
footage like i feel like people look
like here you go could i get the
security cam footage for this prank that
i just pulled
but if he had braced himself at all in
the fall i'd say fake but uh yeah right
that's always the thing it's very hard
to do without a truly
fake fall yeah he's out
like i was saying even with that that
sketch we did the other day with the
thick boy stuff just falling to my knees
without bracing myself it's like god
damn that hurts my head yeah it's just
counterintuitive yeah yeah it's almost
and then what do you think about the guy
not helping him
i like i like it
you know why because he's like i've seen
this before you're not dead wake up i'm
not gonna freak out i like that energy
very masculine
so this is what happens when you take
creatine this is true okay
so i know i should know the name of this
old professional wrestler but he threw
i've seen this clip before he throws the
ball all the way up in the air and then
waits like two seconds he's like i'm so
cocky about how fast i am
and even though he's running in slow-mo
we can tell
he's not that fast at all but he throws
it all the way up in the air runs across
the football field gets under it
but who knows maybe maybe his uh
calculation of the trajectory of the
football was so good that he was able to
pull this off in real life i don't know
haters will say it's it's photoshop
haters will say it's special effects
taken forever yeah it's just like wow
dude
but uh my friend so when you take
creatine and you just know that's what
they're saying is that you're exploring
videos this is what happens when you
take creatine a lot of people
underestimate the power of creatine
people ask me mark does creatine work i
say
let me show you a little video
okay a lot of people have heard of the
bang bus this is actually the buff bus
and here we have a guy
no excuses all right
he's doing rear delt work on the bus
with a seat belt okay he's doing rear
delt extensions um
before i think he was doing like a lat
pulling exercise we had to pull over
and that just there we go yep see it's
sort of like a bent over pull over type
thing with the tricep kickback at the
end what i'm saying is this guy's on the
bus
obviously semi-homeless yet he's getting
in a full-body workout at just one
station right he has a seat belt with a
little bit of resistance on a public bus
and he's not making any excuses so i'm
going to challenge you guys
we're saying oh mark i can't go to the
gym because i don't have the money to
go to the gym or buy any home equipment
and i just don't have any time because
i'm so busy coming to and from work and
i work a manual labor job and oh my god
my entire family died and it's just me
and do you have any money here's my cash
up if that's you if that's you in my
dm's complaining about the lack of time
and resources that you have to work out
look at the buff bus guy okay he's got
nothing in life and yet he's on the bus
making no excuses he's the ultimate
alpha you want to think andrew tate is
an alpha male because of what he's done
the past few months on instagram
this guy okay not not three-time world
kickboxing champion andrew entertain
this guy on the buff bus okay
uh seat belt sammy i'm gonna call him
he's the alpha male you want to be like
him you want to make no excuses you want
to be getting jacked anywhere and
everywhere
even if it's on a public transportation
automobile got it get it good
i'm out
you